I'll often visit companies or
organizations who are genuinely keen to
learn their wife or I'll meet people who
really driven to learn their what and
they say to me but I can't do it like
you can you're so good at it and the
answer is yeah the only reason I'm good
at it the only reason I sort of it seems
to is out of me a little clearer than
others is because I practice I do it
every single day this is not something I
started yesterday this is this is a
journey I began years ago and I'm
committed to it and I'm constantly
learning about the why I do not consider
myself by any stretch of imagination an
expert in it I consider myself a student
of it and I want to learn about it and
improve I mean like any skill it is it
improves with practice some people may
have natural capacity for it and some
people may have to work much harder than
others to get good at it but either way
it takes a lot of practice and it's like
anything else if you go to a ball game
where you watch gymnastics at the
Olympics they all make it look easy but
there are so many countless hours and
years and sacrifices and blood the sweat
and tears that they went through and
failure after failure after failure so
that when it actually came to game time
it looked easy and that really is the
opportunity I'm a great believer in
practicing in places it doesn't matter
when somebody says what do you do you
know on a plane or at a dinner party
these are the times to practice these
are the times to get used to
articulating your why this is when I
would do it in random places and social
environments where it didn't matter
because if I got it wrong so what and I
would fail a hundred times and
eventually when I started to feel
confident that I started to get a
positive response from someone at a
dinner party then I would use it in a
meeting a human being at a dinner party
as a human being at a meeting it's still
a human being but when it really
mattered I'd done all the practice at
times that it didn't matter and so it
really takes a lot of practice and every
now and then you have the courage to
practice in the live situation as well
but it could also go wrong but like any
any skill just a lot a lot of patience
and a lot of practice nothing else